we produced a music video several years
ago where these people are pulling down
a statue and it's a wheel a new Statue
comes up when one Statue gets pulled
down and then they pull the next one
down and another one comes up
there's a new Statue every time when
group a gets their leader put in Power
Group a doesn't revolt against him the
next Revolution is from Group B
Group B tears down the statue of command
of Captain a and then Group C protests
Group B
so if you get a Donald Trump in power
it's not like one day Trump supporters
go out in stage Revolution no the Trump
supporters are happy with Trump it's the
left that comes out in stages the
culture Evolution then when they put
Biden in it's the Trump supporters that
try to remove so that's why there's
always going to be the cycling this
wheel at cycling but as we develop a two
generations of Youth hyper polarized you
are you are setting the stage for an
outright Civil War